[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 144
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel,
and as always, I'm
here with my colleague,
Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good, Mark.
And I'm here.
We're both here.
MARK MANDEL: We're
here, sort of here.
I'm at home.
You're in the office.
It's fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: All
right, well, Mark,
this week, we're going to
speak with Terry and Taichi
from Mercari.
It's another episode that we
recorded while we were at Next.
And we were really glad to
get them to come in and talk
to us about their e-commerce
platform that operates out
of Japan, the US, and
the UK and the story
that they have around
working with microservices,
as well as migrating
services onto GCP.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And as for always, we'll
have cool things of the week
and our questions of the week.
And the question
of the week will
be, how do I use my existing
identity management system
with Google Cloud Platform?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a great question.
As you mentioned, though,
we're going to start out
with cool things of the week.
And one of them is a GitHub
repo from Sara Robinson
from our team.
She did a repo that
basically helps
demo auto ML and the integration
with Firebase Storage.
So if you wanted to experiment
with querying a custom auto ML
model from a web app, you
can look at her example.
This actually uses
some of the data
that she also did an example
on earlier in the year
when we talked about
it during episode 108.
And we also talked about
auto ML at that time.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another auto
ML point that we wanted to cover
is that there is
this article, and it
steps through putting
together an example of auto ML
using data to help
classify graffiti artists.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really cool.
It goes through basically
how they used auto ML
to take a bunch of
data and sort of align
it with particular
artists, as well as
how they improved it
once they built it
as well, which is kind of nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And then another cool
thing of the week,
we also want to mention
Colt McAnlis, who's
another one of our teammates.
And he has recently published
another Performance Atlas
video.
It's a great video series that
he's been putting out there.
In this one, he says he is
helping cryptocurrency fans
with their data
store transactions.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
Hitting the buzzwords.
He's hitting the buzzwords.
MELANIE WARRICK: He's totally
hitting the buzzwords.
MARK MANDEL: It wouldn't
be a podcast episode
if I didn't talk
about Kubernetes.
I'm really excited
about this too.
So there's a blog post
discussing basically
deploying only what
you trust, introducing
binary authorization for
Google Kubernetes Engine.
Basically, this is
all about how do
I trust what is running on
my production infrastructure.
So making sure that
only the things
that you want to have running
on your Kubernetes clusters
are the things that are running
on the Kubernetes cluster.
I mean, this could be a
whole episode in itself.
But there's a couple of
really cool things in there.
They have image in
repository white listing
as a great way of
basically saying, here
are the images that you can send
using matching scripts to able
to do that, but also signature
verification for pod generation
2 and ways to do that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What does that mean?
MARK MANDEL: What
does that mean?
Basically, they
verify signatures
against the images that are
running against the container
analysis API.
But there's also open-source
ways of doing this too.
It goes into all the details.
It's really, really nice.
I like this article a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: And there's
some nice animated visuals
in there as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
whoever wrote the blog post--
it looks like [INAUDIBLE] if I'm
pronouncing that even vaguely
right--
nice job on the diagrams.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
I think it's time for us to go
speak with Taichi and Terry.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Let's go do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: We're
happy to have with us today,
Terry Li and Taichi Nakashima,
who are both from Mercari.
And we are grateful
that you guys were
able to join us here at Next.
Thanks for coming.
TERRY LI: Great, thank you.
Great to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So, Terry, can you
tell us a little
bit about yourself
and what you do at Mercari?
TERRY LI: I'm an
engineer at Mercari.
We are working on this
microservice theme
to migrate our back-end from
a monolithic infrastructure
to microservice architecture.
So we are actually
just starting on that.
And Taichi here is building that
platform to run microservices.
And I'm on a team
that's trying to rewrite
the back-end into
microservices that's
running on that platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
All right, so, Taichi, outside
of what Terry's already shared,
what's your background?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: I'm
a software engineer
at Microsoft's platform team.
I'm building the platform top
on the Google Kubernetes engine
so that back end the
engineer [INAUDIBLE]
to easily to deploy
the microservice.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
So actually, for people who
aren't familiar with Mercari,
what is it?
What does it do?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: Mercari
is C2C marketplace So
user can sell their
stuff on our marketplace
and buy it from
their smartphone.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
originally, it's based in Japan?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: Yes,
it's based in Japan.
MELANIE WARRICK: But it's
also accessible in the US?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: Yes.
TERRY LI: We have millions
of users in the US.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I was going to say,
can you share how big is the
platform, like how many people
use Mercari, in a
broad sense, at least?
TERRY LI: We have millions of
daily active users in Japan.
It's a huge thing in Japan to
sell your used books and stuff.
We're not that big
in the US, but we
are starting to have, like,
tens of millions of downloads
already.
So it's growing
very fast, and we're
excited to see how it's
growing in the coming years.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And what are some of the
other markets that you're in?
TERRY LI: We also have
the app in the UK.
MELANIE WARRICK: And what
are some of the things
that people could sell on--
TERRY LI: It's kind of
everything in Japan.
Recently we started doing
even cars and stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
TERRY LI: It's a
bit complicated.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
That's really interesting.
So have you always
been on Google Cloud,
or did you migrate
from somewhere else?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA:
All the Mercari
is running on the on-premise
in Japanese provider.
So we are trying to migrate from
on-premise to the GCP platform
now.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
And you specifically-- I think
you said as well-- you said,
specifically, you're working
on GKE or Kubernetes engine.
Is the platform doing that?
Can you tell us a bit more
about how that's going?
TERRY LI: His team
actually started
working on that platform that
utilizes GKE and other GCP
products to allow us to develop
services on that platform.
So on my team, we're trying
to deploy new microservices
into that platform.
So far, it's been
going well, I'd say.
We have a couple of
services running on it.
It allows the
developers to iterate
on their services in
a much faster speed
without relying on a SRE team
to deploy their code for them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
What made you decide to use GKE?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: So we
want deploy the application
as a container, because
in microservice world,
each sub-stream should have the
freedom to choose a software
programming language.
So infrastructure point of
view, it reads everything
as part of a container.
It's easy to handle,
because we don't
need take care about
the application
is reading Ruby,
or Python, or Go.
So we want to use a container.
So for deploying
the container, I
think the kind that is a
best choice is Kubernetes.
And the best management
service is GKE,
so that's why we chose GKE.
MELANIE WARRICK: Did
you have any challenges
with implementing GKE?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: Challenges--
on GKE or Kubernetes,
we can do anything.
So for example, if we
don't use namespace--
so every thing got
default namespace,
and it's getting complex.
Everything is one namespace.
So we need set up the
[INAUDIBLE] namespace
for each microservices.
Also, we need provides
the proper authorization
to each micro sub-stream.
So we need set up some RBAC.
And this stuff is
challenging point for us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Do you automate any of that?
Do you do a continuous
integration?
You're nodding at me.
So I'm going to go
with you're currently
doing that kind of stuff.
TERRY LI: Yeah, we use a lot
of tools to automate that.
For example, we
never actually go
to GCP console to actually
activate by clicking a button.
We use Terraform to
define what we need.
We use Spinnaker to actually
deploy our container
to GKE, things like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
So what are some
upcoming products
that you're excited about in
regards to the current platform
that you've built or
your current setup?
TERRY LI: I'm excited
about GKE on-prem
that you guys just announced,
because we actually
had some challenges interacting
between our on-prem data center
with the services in GKE.
And having to deploy
some service in GKE
and maintain some legacy systems
in the on-prem data center
is kind of a burden.
So if we have GKE
on-prem, we could
deploy all that microservices
both in GKE and the data
centers, so that developers can
focus on their business logic,
and the deploy can be
done to both sides.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
I'd love to go back
to what you were
talking about before as well.
You were talking
about using Spinnaker
and that kind of stuff.
I think, for people
who are potentially
thinking about
CI/CD pipelines, how
have you found that
experience using Spinnaker?
[INAUDIBLE] use something
for testing as well.
How does that normally look
inside what you've built?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: The reason
to choose the Spinnaker?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
TAICHI NAKASHIMA:
In microservice,
each back-end
service engineer need
to handle deploy themselves.
So in [INAUDIBLE],, maybe
central operation team
is doing this stuff.
But microservices, each
team needs to do this.
So we need some way to easily
set up a deployment pipeline.
In kubectl, if you
[INAUDIBLE],, we can deploy.
But if just kubectl
it does not make sure
that deployment
is worked or not.
So because of some
results quota shortage,
maybe deployment may fail.
But if only kubectl
it's difficult to find
the deployment [INAUDIBLE]
we need to check by kubectl
describe what it disk want.
So that's why we need some
special tool for deployment.
And we found that Spinnaker is
easy to create the deployment
pipeline.
And it also checks kubectl
Opera is worked or not.
And if the [INAUDIBLE] fail,
it [INAUDIBLE] pipelines.
So that's why we chose
Spinnaker for deployment.
MARK MANDEL: So
do your developers
have a specific place
they have to put code?
If I'm a developer
working on Mercari,
and I'm like, I wrote some code,
how does Spinnaker find it,
and how does that flow look?
TERRY LI: We use GitHub
to manage our code.
So every code change
goes to GitHub.
It will open you
in a pull request.
They can configure their cr
tool to build their image
for that PR.
And their image will
be posted to GCR.
Spinnaker has the ability
to listen to a repository
and find the images defined
by some regular expression.
So it can automatically
find the image that's
updated for this application.
And you can choose to
automatically deploy
that image to GKE.
MELANIE WARRICK: In the
pipeline that you have,
is there anything you
wish someone would build
that would make it easier?
TERRY LI: There's
one interesting story
about having that
ability to just make
Spinnaker listen to some
repository and deploy stuff.
It used to be not working right.
And then starting from one day--
I think, a few months ago--
it suddenly started working.
So it automatically built
all images in that repository
to the cluster.
So it's trying to deploy
all the historical versions
of our services
that were terrible.
MARK MANDEL: But it's fine now.
You sorted it out now.
TERRY LI: It's fine now.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's good.
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: And
[INAUDIBLE],, everything
need to be configured by GUI.
So we want manage
the pipeline in code
so that it's easy to manage.
We can debut [INAUDIBLE].
So this what we want.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's what you need?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's good to know.
We're doing this at Next.
Outside of seeing
the on-prem for GKE,
what else have you seen that
you've been excited about?
TERRY LI: I'm excited
about the auto ML stuff.
I mean, I'm not an expert
on machine learning,
but I used to play with it.
And I spent a lot of time
trying to build a super-model.
And seeing that being
automated and seeing
I can train a model in
a few clicks, I think,
will save a lot of effort
for many machine learning
engineers.
And I think it'll
also allow people
from business intelligence team
to be able to analyze our log
and automate if they find
interesting conclusions
of our user behaviors, which is
exciting to me and to the team,
I guess.
MELANIE WARRICK: So do you
have certain ways right now
that come to mind on how
you'd want to implement it
once it's made available?
TERRY LI: Because our logs
are already in BigQuery,
and I saw a demo of building
models based on BigQuery data,
I can imagine people without
machine learning skill easily
do user classification or
analyze some user behavior
based on the auto ML technology.
MELANIE WARRICK: Based on
your specific experiences
with your user base
and the content
that you have on your users?
Yeah, that would be
wonderful, especially
in terms of being
able to specialize
your interactions with them.
I know that's a leading need
for many customers out there.
MARK MANDEL: What about you?
What have you happened to see
that you've been particularly
excited about?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: I'm excited
about the cloud service
platform, CSP.
I don't know what
exactly that is,
but I saw the line about
mange the [INAUDIBLE]..
For microservice platform,
I think [INAUDIBLE]
would be the key technology.
So I want to use [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm very excited.
MELANIE WARRICK:
[INAUDIBLE] is very
valuable for being able to
track, especially with so
many systems distributed.
Yeah, for tracking how
performance is happening.
MARK MANDEL: So I'd love to go
back to and hear more about how
your migration is going.
Because it sounds like you've
gone from on-prem monolith
to cloud microservices
in one go?
Is that accurate?
How has that journey been?
TERRY LI: We started
doing it, and we have
deployed some services own GKE.
But the majority of the back-end
is still in our data center
and will probably take a
much longer time to do that.
MARK MANDEL: How have you
been tearing it apart?
What are you doing there?
How's that working?
TERRY LI: We're trying to
find the most important
or the most fundamental
services, like user services
and item services.
An item is something
that a user try to sell.
Finding these most
fundamental services
and make them as microservices,
so that some other team,
when they need a
new feature, they
can utilize these services
to build new features.
So we start from
there, and we try
to move as much as the
system to GKE as possible.
MARK MANDEL: And why
are you doing this?
TERRY LI: I think we
are at a point where
we have more than 100 engineers
working on the same repository.
And it's, like,
half million lines
of code to make a
simple code change.
To modify some
part of a feature,
you have to deploy
the whole thing
and, fingers crossed,
nothing breaks.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Because it never does.
TERRY LI: Right, exactly.
So I think that's
the main reason--
to make our organization
more scalable.
MARK MANDEL: Why the cloud?
Because you could do micro
services on your own hardware.
Why are you coming to the cloud?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA:
The reason the cloud.
So as I said before,
each developer
need to operate their service.
They also need to operate
the database itself.
So we want manage
everything in on premise
is super hard for
normal developers.
If we use the cloud,
they have use of API.
And the developer easily
set up the database
of these managed services.
So that's why we need
move to the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
How are you controlling what
developers are able to do what?
Are you just like, they
can do anything, it's fine?
Or you're being a
bit more restrictive?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA:
At [INAUDIBLE],,
we use the Terraform to
set up the cloud services.
So currently, we manage
whole Terraform configuration
in one repository.
We prepare directory
for each microservices.
And each microservice team
try to send a pull request
to these directory.
And the microservice [INAUDIBLE]
team is always debut that call.
And we check the developer
does not do the [INAUDIBLE]..
So we try to limit that way.
MELANIE WARRICK: You've
already talked a little bit
about this in terms of the
value of having microservices.
But if you were to do
this all over again,
tips, ideas, lessons learned
that you'd recommend?
TERRY LI: Start from the cloud.
Don't make any monolithic.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, we started
five years ago.
My colleagues started
They probably didn't
have the option
to start from what we have here.
That's why we're doing this.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Which is common.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but
there are definitely
lots of people who are
in similar situations.
So if you were like, this is
the best way we've worked out
to be, this is how we do the
conversion of microservices,
or don't do it this way,
what would you recommend?
TERRY LI: I feel like we are
trying to make too many changes
at the same time.
We were trying to
rewrite the code from PHP
with Golang We are trying
to deploy our services
from on-prem DC to the cloud.
And we're trying to migrate
the database from there
to the cloud as well.
The design is from
a monolithic web app
to microservice architecture.
So we're trying to
make so many changes.
I think the difficulty
explodes and sometimes
make things more difficult
than it should be.
MELANIE WARRICK: Before we
let you both go, anything else
that you wanted to
share, any places
that people can find more
information about Mercari
outside of the website?
TERRY LI: We have
an engineering blog.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
TERRY LI: It's mostly
in Japanese though.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, that's OK.
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: But we
have English version--
Japanese and English.
MARK MANDEL: There's
always Google Translate.
It's fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, we'll
point everybody do that.
Yeah, this is great.
So we'll make sure to
get the links from you
and share that in show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
What sort of stuff do you
cover in the engineering blog?
I'd love to know more.
TERRY LI: The kind
of technical stack
we use to the live
engineer and what
is engineer manager and
organizational things,
also to the sort
of events we do.
We do many events in Japan.
So every time we do, we
also announce in our blog.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
are some resources
that you like to go to for
help with some of the building
out the stack that you have?
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: I always
listen to this podcast.
[SOUND EFFECT]
TERRY LI: I always
start from Google.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then you go from there?
TERRY LI: Google my
problem, and it will lead me
to the right place.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Cool.
Thank you.
I appreciate both
of you joining.
And thanks for
sharing your insights.
TERRY LI: Thank you.
Thank you for your ideas.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
thanks for it.
Things are great.
TAICHI NAKASHIMA: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you
again, Taichi and Terry,
for coming on to the podcast
while we were at Next.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
really great episode.
And thanks for sharing
your journey as well
from building a
monolithic application
and then transferring that
over to microservices,
and how that's going,
and all the lessons
you learned along
the ways as well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
how do I use my existing
identity management system
with Google Cloud Platform?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
This is actually a really
interesting question too.
I didn't even realize
this was a thing really.
So basically, by
default, Google Cloud
is tied to Google accounts.
That's kind of how it was built.
But you may have your own
identity management system.
Maybe you use LDAP or
probably some other things
that I'm not even aware of.
And you may want to use
that instead, or basically,
integrate it with Google
Cloud, so that you don't have
to reinvent the
wheel, essentially,
which I think is really cool.
So there's an article
that we will link to.
We'll give you the top
level highlights here that I
think are most important.
But the great thing
is you can do this.
So if you have an existing
identity management system,
you can integrate this thing.
There are a set of prerequisites
to getting started.
You need to identify a domain
that you'll use to set up
your Cloud Identity account.
You'll need to
make sure that you
have someone who can make text
or CNAME changes to your DNS
settings.
And also, to allow your
users to authenticate
against your identity
[INAUDIBLE] system,
you'll need to implement
SAML single sign on.
We'll talk a little
bit about that too.
So if you can do
those three things,
you can configure the ability
to use third-party identity
management.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Couple other things
we want to mention
from the article
as well is that they recommend
doing a proof of concept
to basically don't synchronize
everything all at once.
Try synchronizing a small number
of users or a small group.
And experiment with
that first to make sure
that your criteria
and your configuration
is properly set before
you do synchronization.
They also mention you don't
need to necessarily map
your entire organization.
It's important to
plan what you really
need to synchronize
and then go from there.
They do have some pointers
around mapping out
the functional
roles for your users
and creating groups
to map to those roles.
Grant roles to a
Google Group instead of
to individual users
when possible,
because it's easier to add and
remove members from a group
than it is to update
the IAM policy itself.
So those are some tips.
And they also do not
default transfer passwords.
They will do a
transfer of the users.
But the passwords themselves
are not necessarily
synced up on default.
MARK MANDEL: And
it's worth noting
that there are two
different ways of doing
the synchronization.
There's Google Cloud
directories sync,
which will sync on a schedule.
But then you can also have
third-party identity providers
do a direct connection as well.
Each kind of has it's
pros and cons depending on
what systems you
already have set,
how easy it is to
use third party,
or whether you just
want to do regular syncs
on a regular basis.
But you can look at
both options as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
the main thing to note
is that I know it's
difficult to spend time
when you've got so many other
things going on to think
about identity management.
But it's really,
crucial, and it's useful,
and it's important.
And resources like this are
helpful in trying to make
it a little easier for you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, I know
you're running off
to the airport at
some point soon.
And I know I'm running off to
the airport at some point soon.
What are you up to?
Where are you going?
What are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm just
doing some training this week.
But where are you
going to be, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: So
when this comes out,
I will still be at
PAX Dev, and then I'll
be hanging out at PAX
West for a good chunk
of the rest of the week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
For those listeners
who don't know, what is PAX?
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] PAX is an
80,000 strong game conference.
PAX West, this is the
big PAX conference.
Several days before
is PAX Dev, which
is a game developer conference,
where everyone gets together,
talks about making games.
I'll be talking about
Agones, which will be fun.
A couple of weeks after that,
I'll be up at Japan Next.
I'll also be talking
about games and Agones
and chatting with a bunch
of customers and stuff,
so it'll be fun.
First time in Tokyo,
so I'm quite excited.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
your first time in Tokyo?
MARK MANDEL: My
first time, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
for me, in September, I'm
going to be in Stellenbosch,
which is outside of Cape Town.
And I'm going to be at
deep learning INDABA.
It's a conference
on machine learning.
And the plan is for me to
do a couple of interviews
for the podcast out
of Stellenbosch.
And then after that,
Mark, you and I
are going to be at Strange
Loop, where we will also
be doing another
podcast recording
that I'm looking forward to.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank you for
joining me on the podcast
once again this week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]